quick liim was also incredibly useful in
times of plague because it aided in the
decomposition of the
corpses the Black Death was the Great
Apocalypse of the Middle Ages when black
rats spread the worst plague in human
history a time of true Terror when carts
went through Villages collecting corpses
dead bodies were stacked in great
stinking heaps the population of the
world plummeted and would not recover
for another 300
years to save Humanity the diseased
infectious corpses needed to be disposed
of as quickly as possible because it
burns on contact with anything moist
quick lime was used to dissolve the
bodies it actually served as a kind of
bleach medieval people would bury plague
victims with quick lime to accelerate
the decomposition of the body and
thereby prevent spread of the plague